so a lot of people get really upset with
me when I tell someone to get married
so let's just kind of understand yeah
there's a moral component to that for me
I'm a Christian or a spiritual component
to that for me I'm a Christian that is
not what's driving the discussion as
much as the practicality and actually
they all do work together there's a
reason morals have are there there's a
reason spiritual guidelines are there
from God but aside from that whether
you're a person of faith or not the data
points are there let me kind of walk you
through this professor bill Galston who
was president clinton's domestic policy
adviser and a senior fellow at Brooklyn
Brewery
he said listen to this in America today
in North America you only need to do
three things to avoid living in poverty
statistically marry before having a
child have that child after age 20
graduate from high school before you do
any of that graduate first get married
before kids have kids after 20 and 97%
of the time you do not live at the
poverty level statistically those are
called data points when you get simple
things like that in the right order now
if you didn't do that I'm not mad at you
and I'm not shaming you I've done a lot
of stupid things in my life but don't
get all pissed off at me and call me all
these names because you feel condemned
because you got stuff out of order
that data points say this is Brookings
Institute this is not the Catholic
Church or the Southern Baptist
Convention
this is Brookings doing statistical data
analysis 97% of the time that you
graduate from high school before having
a child get married before having a
child and have the child after age 20
you will not live your life at the
poverty level when you get those things
out of the order it exponentially goes
up that you will be living at the
poverty level so that's why I talk to a
young man like that because I care about
him and I know what the data points are
these are statistical I mean when you
have a if you know anything about
statistics I mean people when they're
doing elections like presidential
elections if you can get anywhere up in
the high 40s they start declaring you I
have a victory right if you got a 48%
you know you're probably gonna be
president you know that kind of thing
51% this is 97% that's like every time
stupid that's what that means
another report shows us that focusing on
millennial Millennials the same number
comes up ninety seven percent of those
who follow the success sequence earn the
high school diploma work and marry
before having children will not be poor
as they enter their 30s and that is true
of all ethnicities in this study another
study only 4% of homes with a married
mother and father in the home are on
food stamps 21 percent of the homes
where people are cohabitating and 28
percent of the single mother homes are
on food stamps only four percent or a
married mother and a married father are
in the home with the child there's a
direct tie between how you view family
structure
and your economic benefits there's a
direct data point to this and it goes on
and on and on and on and on from there
well 52 percent of the marriages end in
divorce no they don't no they don't
number one that statistics just
straight-up bogus people made that up
and it's one of those Snopes things you
can't find it you cannot find the piece
of research that says that what you can
find is if you graduate from college if
you regularly attend a house of faith
regardless of the type of faith Jewish
Muslim Christian whatever you regularly
attend the house of faith you graduate
from college you get married before
having children you have children after
you graduate from college you make
$50,000 a year household income or
greater your divorce rate is only about
four percent these are all variables you
can control so the divorce rate happens
among different socioeconomic settings
people who make different choices in
their lives and they get themselves
painted into a corner and it blows their
marriage up there and you can keep going
from there by the way if you want to
just keep studying all these indicators
of a stable character-based life and you
always see that tied back to economic
data we saw it when we started studying
millionaires of 10,000 millionaires we
studied in that research project we saw
it again in there now we weren't
researching to find the socio-economic
decisions and that the the so-called
success sequence that's in these you
know graduate high school then get
married then have kids after 20 that's
assist the research success sequence
that's been done on several projects but
guys if you wanna you know here's the
thing you make you got three kids and
you make under $30,000 of your household
income you're right at the poverty level
according to federal recording the Fed
statistics of what the poverty level is
you're single you make $17,000 a year
you're at the poverty level
now is that a bad thing no I'm one year
I made $6,000 I know how it feels I'm
not I'm not talking down to anybody I'm
a redneck hillbilly guys I get it okay I
understand I've been there I am that guy
at times I've done all kinds of stupid
but stuff in my life but the thing is
there's a whole lot of the things that
happen in your life the vast majority of
them that are holding you back that are
your choices
they're your choices substance abuse
your work ethic your decision to work
while you're at work your decision to
tell the truth and be a person of
integrity your decision to not steal
these are all decisions that you can
make and they affect the course of your
life they affect you this week next week
and ten years from now and there is a
high correlation between those kinds of
character based decisions and whether or
not you succeed financially it is not
merely a debt snowball guys if you like
eat steal and sleep around on your wife
the debt snowball is not going to help
you much because marriage is grand but
divorce is 50 grand you get to cut
everything in half when you do that and
start again try cutting it in half about
three times and starting again you got
to make a whole lot of stinking money to
offset that puppy it's cheaper to keep
her baby I'm telling you these life
choices are real but in this politically
correct speech Nazi culture that we live
in we're not allowed to say out loud
that your character impacts your life
well I just did and there's 17 million
of you listening and if you're if you're
really upset with me right now it's okay
you can go listen to somebody else I
understand I'm not mad
but they call this the Dave Ramsey show
for a reason because it's my freakin
show if you don't like what I'm saying
and you want to say something else get
you a show this is the Dave Ramsey show